devo
scusarmi perché
fare il paragone tra barcellona e napoli
il paragone livelli di felicità di tutti
quanti però quando mi hanno detto o 10
minuti ho detto vabbè barcellona passa
ancora 5 minuti ma napoli è detto questo
ho cambiato di titolo e si chiama
emotion in the city e mi dispiace anche
per questo perché l'ho lasciato in
inglese con una volta ce la faceva fatto
così e motion e nei siti sì perché non
funziona anni fa
cor maurice benayoun questo amico
francese che pure è anche un più grandi
artisti del digitale che nel mondo oggi
avevamo la discussione su mi piacerebbe
diceva lui di vedere in tempo reale in
tutte le città una grande mappa e che
sarebbe darebbe punti di problemi in
tempo reale a partire da una
quantificazione delle sensori che ne so
l'idea era questa
anni dopo vif crea la prima cosa che lui
la simulazione prende 32.000 città
distribuite sul mondo e dà la
possibilità alla gente sulla rete di
scegliere tra 20 20 e mosè 156 e
chiedere la frequenza della nomina di
quest'emozione le varie città del mondo
e porta così una mappa del mondo dove
molto approssimativo appariva tivamente
si può leggere il sentimento al raggio
di questa zona
allora li ha fatto continua a lavorare
su di questo
questa è una
grande è fatta
ma parità
fa un paragone tra il mondo
dell'economia e un mondo dell'emozione
crea a partire dalla stessa presa più
formazione la predizione dell'emozione
dominante una zona per morto e sopra fa
vedere anche l'investimento delle
investimenti e dimensioni e satirica è
assolutamente chiara
e allora dimensione del in l'interesse
di questi veramente speciali bene
andiamo alla prossima possiamo chiudere
non si chiude
la sua
e così va il brasiliano eccola che
adesso questo sì allora questo non si
vede bene e mi dispiace perché non posso
veramente descrivere la cosa a loro
scritto la posizione di trento e al
quadro a destra si tratta di due misure
in uno della smartness della città di
intelligenza avrò che a partire di peter
e l'altro è stato di benessere della
città e la corrispondenza non è
assolutamente chiara come si vede però
la buona notizia per trento e che si
trova la più a destra alla metà del
quadro di destra superiore questi i
padroni destra superiore superiore vuol
dire che trento si trova veramente a una
media molto alta della smart mans e
della felicità ma la cosa che si vede
che non vedono non vengono insieme
necessariamente adesso abbiamo una
situazione dentro di che l'emozione non
è più locale e come l'opinione pubblica
non è più locale e globale
vuol dire che le emozioni circola oggi a
partire dalla rete creando una
situazione emotiva della planeta e del
pianeta che assolutamente diverso allora
non faccio la loro analisi perché il
tempo passa però tutti questi da field
da twitter a facebook a youtube e tutti
quanti ti portano emozione per tutto e
si condividono infatti web 2.0 e web
relazionale vuol dire web dentoni che la
gente si sta vivono emozione bene le
muse alle normali della città può essere
puntuali come quella grande paura
chiaramente dopo la caduta delle torri
di new york può essere organizzata come
questo che è successo a washington
quando per 23 giorni
uscendo almeno sette persone sniper
letteralmente terrorizzava tutta la
città per una cosa sorprendente che
quando usano dei big data per sapere
esattamente che tipo di emozione o di
credi paura diciamo preoccupi di più la
gente veneti qui un 3 grande picca rosso
giallo e l'arancio sono tre momenti di
epidemia stars l'influenza a via quella
del maiale allora che la sinistra si
trova letteralmente la la parte la più
la più piccola che era la paura dal del
terrorismo la paura del momento del 11
questa è una cosa che non si può
immaginare si deve sapere a partire
della ricerca sulla rete un'altra cosa
assolutamente divertente
questo è la mappa del capodanno
l'anno scorso che studiava in tempo
reale tutti i tweet partire le parole
chiave del twitter no tutti i tweet che
esprimevano un desiderio un come dire
una risoluzione di capodanno no e si
vede in rosso tutti i tweet che sono
altruisti ti voglio bene vuole fare
qualcosa per te mi piacerebbe quest'anno
tutti che sono in blu sono narcisisti a
me volevo fare più cose ma se alla mia
salute mi fermo dissi di fumare qualche
no per fare più soldi
sinceramente però la cosa interessante è
questa mappa emozionale possiamo dire
che un riflettono di emozione di tutto è
un paese a un certo momento mi sembra
che una cosa pertinente di come dire
avere mi piacerebbe sulla sul mio delia
di vedere arrivare questa mappa delle
emozioni del mio paese al momento no
allora ci sono adesso emozione globali
voi sapete forse che è successo con la
persona che ha incominciato di
abbracciarsi nel mondo intero perché un
ragazzo di sedili aver pensato un buona
idea di fare a braccio gratis nella
strada ed è divenuto un fenomeno
mondiale che adesso a dieci anni fa però
è una cosa come primi grande emozione
globale harlem shaq è una follia globale
che tutte le avete forza corrette voi
avesse altamente provato questo e allora
te le cose interessare qualche si
interessano le mando la flight di dda
esattamente come si fa bene però però
c'è anche questo c'è anche la rabbia
l'emozione può prendere tutta mondo
inside job essendo un film che ha fatto
vedere un documentario infatti come gli
stati e le banche si organizza tra di
loro per non vuole dire una parola
brutta però da noi non si fregano molto
diciamo benedetto questo succede che
arriva
tir e di queste questo sentimento globe
che cresce nel mondo o nella città un
momento di emozione e passa all atto e
ha cominciato a barcellona con los
indignados dove al barcellona ha
cominciato di mettersi alla piazza
catalunya per organizzarsi per
protestare contro a questa il gioco
delle banche e dello stato
io adesso intanto sono in partenza per
messico per discutere un problema è che
veramente è vicino di questi come
aiutare come usare della rete per
aiutare il sentimento di comunità e per
approdare più momento la gente della
periferia a quello del centro perché
cmmc così ti è una città che ha
cresciuto in larghezza non in altezza
vuol dire che è che norme 20 milioni di
persone è un po un problema sia di come
fare come usare la rete per raramente
creare sentimento di comunità
questo è uno delle più belle cose che si
possono dire sulle la felicità di un
città ove un paese è il re di boot anche
in 72 ha detto è molto più importante
il prodotto del prodotto nazionale brut
totale è molto importante la felicità
nazionale totale e ha creato per questo
una scuola di pensiero e a
un'applicazione di governo che contiene
un criteri che parti può dare la tempo
ancora che può che può dare la felicità
a partiti per chi terry e possiamo
vedere c'è prima di tutto quello che in
alto la di sentimenti benessere interno
il sentimento di dimensione come dirà di
equilibro emozionale di spiritualità
chiaramente un paese che è molto vicino
del buddismo e anche della conoscenza
dei problemi
qualche cosa secondo l'uso del tempo la
porzione di sveglio e e sogno la
comunità pratica della comunità la con
la fiducia il supporto anche la densità
di questa comunità e tutte le cose
vitalità di famiglia e altre cose tutto
questi sono studiati per vedere se le
cose vanno bene vuole una consulenza tra
la popolazione e il governo per
assicurare che arriviamo almeno a questo
livello di felicità
io direi che questa era norma veramente
invasa da bertone cose il sogno in aria
ora finiscono su un'altra cosa
del mio amico mi svegliai un possiamo
farlo andare
questo è la fronte di un questo è da
fronte la stazione centrale di seul in
corea e lui ha ripreso la stessa cosa
per diffusa re alla città la gente che
arriva escono della stazione che
finalmente il nostro rapporto
questa vita è un rapporto che porta
piuttosto alla fede che devo può fare la
felicità piuttosto che al denaro dei
sempre questo paragone tra le tra le due
che che penso arrivando a un certo modo
nelle varie suggerimenti che abbiamo i
segni voti io vedo che c'è un
cambiamento modo profondo della nostra
società
lenta con problemi ma una tendenza
un'etica che potrebbe farsi portata al
sulla felicità della gente e condivisi
non la vedo proprio così grazie